this is the true cost of the crisis in
nhs dentistry that has been building for
over a decade once she gave me the
treatment plan i burst into tears and
ended up having a panic attack in the
seat because it's just so expensive it
came to a total of
1065 pounds
and that was just to start because she
did say that that might not fix the
problems
patients in extraordinary pain unable to
get treatment unless they can come up
with the cash to go private
lydia's had three fillings fallout and
has a wisdom tooth growing into her
cheek she lives in somerset an area
known as a dentistry desert where
getting an nhs appointment is near
impossible and it's pushing people to
the edge
i actually had an overdose of
painkillers because
the tooth pain was so bad that i didn't
want
i just didn't want to be awake anymore
so i didn't really care what happened if
i took too many if i
died or just didn't wake up it didn't
bother me
far from a one-off this is becoming
commonplace across the country james is
in brisbane edmonds and has a broken
tooth unable to afford the six thousand
pounds he was quoted to get it removed
privately he took matters into his own
hands i just got to the point where i
snapped and i um took a knife and
tried to
loosen the tooth sadly i sort of slipped
and i've cut the inside of my gums
and then obviously there was loads of
blood if something's not done soon
it's going to happen again
because i need help
and
no one can help me
exclusive numbers given to sky news show
that pre-existing pressures on the
dentistry industry intensified hugely
when the pandemic hit coveted
restrictions saw the number of nhs
appointments plummet with an estimated
43 million lost including over 13
million for children
so we could offer you a private
appointment
are you in any pain at all
at this north london practice they do
still offer new nhs appointments but
they're one of the only places in the
area that does
just a checkup today everything okay for
you yeah
dentist lender crews warns that years of
underfunding has forced many of his
colleagues out or into private practice
nhs dentistry is dying he says and it's
the next generation that will suffer
most the most common reason why children
end up in uh in hospitals is for gene is
for extractions for general anesthetic
extraction so it's horrendous we're
we're in the 21st century with the fifth
uh richest nation in the world yet we
have a system where people are taking
their own teeth ads it's victorian
values and the government has just
watched this happening they've been
asleep at the wheel
back in suffolk a desperate mother who
wants to remain anonymous hopes that the
situation will improve for her three
young boys none of whom have ever seen a
dentist my lds did have problems for a
little while
he actually got an abscess on one of his
teeth and i couldn't get him in anywhere
and obviously he was only seven at the
time
and
you know for a seven year old to feel
that pain is awful you know he didn't
know how to cope with it i can see why
you know
parents and children you know
just desperate to get out of pain and
pulling their own teeth out she knows
firsthand how bad things can get and has
shared these pictures with us to show
how her teeth have deteriorated over
many years
so what's her message to those in power
please i'd beg you know i've been
waiting you know
years just just to get even registered
to be seen and to be you know have a
checkup you know that's all i'm asking
the department of health says last year
it gave an extra 50 million pounds to
fund 350 000 extra dental appointments
and they're working with the nhs to
reform the system but for those in pain
now will it be enough liz bates sky news